Oh cycroid I'm no expert but this
doesn't seem real to me
fishermen Sudeep Ong Santa dish claims
to have caught this unusual worm off the
coast of Thailand but can something this
gross be genuine this might look like
something at a horror film and I would
really love to think that it's not real
but it really is so what in the name of
science is this thing this creepy little
guy is called a proboscis worm that has
this structure the proboscis which it
injects either to entrap some prey or in
the case of this video - perhaps deter
some kind of predator it's probably
feeling threatened and so as an active
defense spits this thing out and then
the proboscis will be drawn back inside
why doesn't this little guy pull his
proboscis back in when this worm is
outside the water that mucus actually
feels stickier and it gets stuck to
Sutra Pauling's hand so it can't
actually pull its proboscis back and
instead the proboscis breaks off now
this may sound lethal but actually these
worms can regenerate their proboscis and
they can go without food for a long time
while they wait for it to regenerate you
guys may think it looks gross but I
think it illustrates the beauty of the
word